MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture, we look
at the interaction of W bosons
with quarks, or the charged
weak interaction of quarks.
Let's just make a
number of observations.
Now, we observe that the weak
interaction respects the lepton
generation, meaning
that a W couples
to an electron and
an electron neutrino,
but not an electron
muon neutrino.
But in the case of the quarks,
there is violation of this.
So there is a disrespect
of the quark generation
when it comes to the
interaction with Ws.
So when you investigate
these two diagrams here,
you find that the W couples to
the V quark and the U quark,
but it also couples
to the S quark.
S quark and the U
quark, all right?
In order to encapsulate this,
we have to make a correction.
And the corrections
are typically
called cosine theta C
and sine theta C. Theta
C is the Cabibbo angle,
so theta Cabibbo.
Turns out this is rather
small, so it's a decrease.
So it is a correction,
a small correction.
We studied the
partial decay width
of the kaon in leptonic
decays over the partial decays
to a pion of the pion
in leptonic decays.
We found that there
is a set of forms
that are the form factor
for the pion decay
and a form factor
for the kaon decay.
It turns out that
the form factors are
due to this
additional correction,
so you find the tangent-square
of the Cabibbo angle
as part of this correction.
Good.
So far, so good.
Now we have made an observation.
We haven't explained
anything yet.
We can make one more
observation, or discuss one,
and that's the decay of neutral
kaons to a pair of muons.
It turns out that those
are not very likely.
Even so, you would expect that
the amplitude has a factor here
of sine and cosine of
Cabibbo, so the amplitude
should be on the order of sine
theta Cabibbo times cosine
theta Cabibbo.
So when this was
studied, the charm quark
hadn't been discovered.
And the explanation to why
this decay is suppressed
comes from the fact that there
is a second diagram here,
where we just replace the U
quark in this rule with a C
quark.
This diagram contributes there's
a minus sign to the amplitude.
And therefore, those two
diagrams, they cancel.
Right?
They are the same magnitude,
about the same magnitude,
and they have an opposite sign.
So this was the first
indication that there
must be a force
quark contributing
to this kind of process.
That's the charm quark.
Let me now try to understand
what's going on here.
Why is the W coupling modified?
Or why is not the full
down quark or charm
and strange quark participating
in the weak interaction?
We can do the following here.
We can rewrite-- we note
that the weak interaction
eigenstate, the eigenstate which
participate in the [INAUDIBLE],,
is not the eigenstate
of the particle
itself, the so-called
mass eigenstate.
So we have to write
the weak eigenstate
as the linear combination of the
mass eigenstate or [INAUDIBLE]..
This can be done
in this matrix form
here, where we simply
multiply the weak eigenstates
with a matrix, and just
basically rotate it
into the mass eigenstate.
So this was proposed by
Cabibbo, and rather successful.
But it didn't incorporate the
third-generation particle.
And this was done by
Kobayashi and Maskawa,
who generalized the scheme
and proposed the so-called CKM
matrix, the easier
form Cabibbo--
Cabibbo, Kobayashi, and Maskawa.
Because of constraints
we'll discuss
in one of the
recitations, this matrix
can be parameterized as only
three independent angles
and one complex phase as
independent parameters.
So you can choose
different parameterization
to capture that there's only
four parameters in this matrix,
which has nine components.
One is by thinking
about this matrix
as three independent rotations
and this complex phase here.
In terms of
numerical values, you
see that the diagonal
elements of this matrix
are very close to 1,
meaning that this mixing is
on the block sector of
the [INAUDIBLE] effect.
You find that those next-nearest
off-diagonal elements are
on the order of 20%, and the
next-to-next off-elements
are even smaller.
OK?
This leads us, then,
to the discussion
that we can use different
parameterization in order
to capture [INAUDIBLE].
We already discussed the
standard parameterization,
which you can really think
about three different rotation.
And the values of those
angles are give here, together
with the value of
this additional phase.
Another way to look at this
is the so-called Wolfenstein
parameterization.
And this captures
the fact that it
seems like that there's
a correction being
applied to the actual particle.
So you find elements
of the order of lambda.
Lambda is about 22%.
And you find elements
which are in the order of 1
minus the lambda-square
correction.
And then there is elements which
are of lambda-square and lambda
3rd power.
So this captures the
matrix, and then there's
higher-order corrections to
that which are of order lambda
to the 4th power.
OK?
Because there's constraints on
this matrix-- and specifically,
unitarity constraints, meaning
that we have three generations
that will make a mixing of
those three mass eigenstates
to weak eigenstate-- then
unitarity, the total number
of particles in this
discussion, is conserved.
This will change if there
would be, for example, a force
generation particle.
So the study of weak-charged
interaction with quarks
helps us to understand
whether or not there
might be a force generation.
We'll not go into
too much detail here,
but also, the complex
phase explains
part of our understanding
of CP violation.
And we might discuss this in a
little bit of a later lecture.
But nevertheless, what
we can achieve from here
is those unitarity
constraints, just simply
summing over the
matrix elements,
the scalar product
of matrix elements.
And those where the
contribution vanishes,
so those where j
and k are not equal,
those can be represented
as a triangle.
That's kind of interesting.
You can just rewrite this.
You just say that those
three elements of the sum
are equal to 0.
Then you normalize
by one element.
In this case here,
normalize by Vcd, Vcb.
And so then this makes
this point being 0,
and so we have
this nice triangle
here, which has three
angles, alpha, beta,
and gamma, and this
point here, rho and eta.
And so this is a nice
way to illustrate
actual measurements of
the elements of the CKM
matrix [INAUDIBLE].
And without actually explaining
how we do this experiment,
you can assume that
all measurements have--
well, you can understand
that all measurements
have to do with the weak
interaction with quarks.
That's how we have access
to the CKM matrix elements.
Sometimes this results in
the modification of masses
or splitting of mass
states, and sometimes
the direct measurement
cause a recoupling.
When you put all of those
measurements back together,
you can look at this.
So we see our triangle here.
We see this point, eta and
rho, which is given here
in this right-angular plane.
And you see various number of
measurements which correspond
to elements of this CKM matrix.